there we go
so
apologize for the uh Growing Pains here
to get this started
and my name is Stuart Creek I'm with
simply learn and we are the delivery
partner
for the Caltech Center for technology
and a management education data science
boot camp
among other programs we deliver for
Caltech today we're here to do a free
sample class from the curriculum of the
data science boot camp on inferential
statistics
and we're here with one of um
our most senior instructors as I
mentioned shubham Pandi
aye
he has let him
introduce himself a bit more before he
gets into the lesson
um
11 years of experience in data science
it's facilitated workshops
for number of Fortune 500 companies as
well as universities training Institutes
the
strategy consultant in the field of data
science including in statistical
modeling and machine learning
so he's
very well qualified to bring you an
industry perspective on this as part of
its instruction
and we'll talk about the curriculum of
the data science boot camp
we'll do some
script or background of inferential
statistics why it's important and then
we'll get into the live lesson
and we'll do a recap so
as I say the Caltech data science boot
camp is a comprehensive program
that takes you from the very Basics to
uh the practical
if capability instead of skills around
data science
start off with Statistics and then move
into R and Python programming applied
science
with python machine learning uh Tableau
for visualization you sum it all up with
a Capstone project where you apply all
of those skills that you've learned in
the program into one industry aligned
project that becomes the
Jewel in your portfolio that you can
probably show off the people as your
experience and your set of new skills
demonstrated plus you get access to the
electives at no additional cost based on
your interest in your schedule you can
take business analytics Excel SQL
training power bi and the master classes
from Caltech faculty
so you can get pretty far into data
science and machine learning through
this program
and
I will turn it over to
Shivam tell us a bit about inferential
statistics
hi Stuart
and hi everybody
uh thanks for having me here uh let me
share my screen
a very good evening uh good morning to
all of you uh so very excited to uh
talk to you here on YouTube live for
First YouTube live this year for me uh
and I'm pretty excited
uh to meet you all
and I hope you all are equally excited
uh let's get going let's get started
with inferential statistics
so
uh do you see my screen my screen is
visible
yes it is
great
so this is the LMS simply learn LMS
learning management system
so I'll go to my courses and
and then I'll come down here here I've
got Caltech post graduate program in
data science I'll click here on program
and hey it takes me to all these courses
it starts from statistics Essentials and
then python then apply data science and
all and then at the end Tableau and
Capstone projects
we want to discuss here something
related to statistics so I'll go to data
science
I'll click here
so this element is for your information
it's a One-Stop shop
for all your learning needs here you
will find all the content
all the self-paced videos you'll find
here assessment your attendance will be
here only you'll be able to join classes
from here so I'll stop shop for you
and here I'll go to practice lab
so this practice lab
is a cloud-based lab
and I'll be able to write
python codes here on Jupiter notebook
so I launched lab here you go
[Music]
it takes some time to get started
one of the good things about this
feature is that you don't need to set up
an environment on your local machine
because it's
available through this
virtual environment correct
absolutely uh Stuart and second thing is
that in your real life uh work whatever
whatever organization uh people join
over there most of the time they'll be
walking on cloud-based tools so when we
promise that we create industry ready
professionals
uh it is also one important point we
take care of
so let me open here
statistics fundamentals the topic which
we are going to discuss today is a very
fundamental topic but very interesting
so first of all let me set the agenda
here will be first of all learning what
is the statistics
a little
uh understanding about his statistics
will develop we'll look into the types
of his statistics
we'll understand
descriptive statistics briefly
inferential statistics briefly
and then we'll be discussing one case
one case study will go through because I
think that will be fun for you you would
always like to understand the
application part where statistics will
be useful for us
so we'll be discussing one case we'll
have some chat we'll have some
discussion feel free to ask your
questions feel free to share your
thoughts share your ideas
and let's have fun in the remaining uh
part of the session yeah ready to go
great
so statistics
I would say uh for
a data analyst it is very important that
uh
one Masters
tool in terms of tool that may be python
that maybe are that may be SAS or any
visualization to like Tableau power bi
so tools
and then after tools it is about
domain knowledge it's about industry
knowledge it's about the knowledge of
the area where you want to apply it
and the third point which is uh
something we are going to discuss here
is the statistics the techniques part
so in techniques statistics applied
statistics
these are like very very important for
us
so what is the statistics statistics is
a discipline that deals with
methodologies to collect data data
collection is very important
collecting data from different sources
data sources may be
uh different servers
data warehouses social media platforms
data source may be an Excel file as well
okay so you need to know how to collect
the data from different sources and what
to collect
depending on the problem you're solving
after you collect your data data may not
be in the form
in the format which is suitable for
further analysis so what you do you
prepare to prepare your data you prep
your data for future analysis further
analysis
and after that you do the analysis in
analysis you come across different types
of analysis and after you do the
analysis the next part is interpretation
whatever number you have come up with
that you should be able to interpret
in perspective you should be able to
interpret the numbers in perspective of
the visual situation
so these all steps
uh when you perform you need statistics
okay there are common uh terms used in a
statistic like population
sample
so population is the complete data pool
from where a sample is drawn population
is that set of object around which you
make a decision
and Sample is a part of the population
sample is the subset of the population
which you always try to make as
representative of the population as
possible
then we have measurement
a measurement is a number or attribute
calculated for each member of the
population or sample
sometimes this is referred to as summary
measure
sometimes it is referred to as a metric
parameter
okay
we come across variables
and we also look at the distribution so
we don't have enough time to go through
all these in detail
in our live classes we actually go
through all these things in big detail
with the help of different examples with
the help of different cases
but here we are uh
meeting for inferential statistics
so types of Statistics we have
descriptive statistics
differential statistics
uh predictive is the predictive
statistics
that can also be considered as a part of
interracial
so as the very name suggests what is
descriptive statistics uh I think you
should be able to understand the idea
about it
what is descriptive statistics by the
way
what do you think is descript
descriptive statistics
which helps you describe
which helps you characterize
absolutely
thanks for your responses
so like when you meet any individual
what you do you try to describe that
individual you try to characterize that
individual based on various parameters
based on education ethnicity
based on physical appearance
based on the language
etc etc the same way
a data analyst
a data scientist should be able to
describe the data
okay data is described based on summary
measures I talked about that
a couple of minutes back
so we use measures of central tendency
measures of possession
measures of dispersion
you all must have used mean median mode
standard deviation variance Etc
so these all are used to describe your
data
okay
information statistics we use
when we need to draw conclusions about
the population
when we don't have access to the whole
population
we are not able to reach the whole
population it is too big
or there are other obstacles
having the whole population with us
it is difficult to describe the whole
population
in that scenario what we do
we don't hold back we don't say that we
can't do the analysis what we do in that
scenario
we take a small part of the data
we extract a small part of the data
absolutely
I agree with you thanks for your
response
folks please keep responding keep
interacting let's have fun let's not
make a monotonous one-way communication
let's interact we are meeting for the
first time I think right so let's have
fun keep asking questions
so information statistics again the very
name if you look at it is about making
inferences
so what you do when you don't have
access to the whole population you work
with the sample
you collect a sample yes when you
collect the sample you have to be
careful you try your best
within the constraint you're walking
because you always walk under different
constraints
budget constraints resource constraints
time constraints So within the
constraints you try to have your sample
as representative as possible of the
population
after collecting your sample you perform
the analysis based on Sample so with the
help of sample analysis you try to make
inferences for the whole population
that's what you do in information
statistics basically
so here in information statistics
you work under uncertainties
it is not a deterministic way of
calculation
so you come across terms like random
variable
so we do the analysis of random variable
here in inferential statistics
okay
information statistics allows us to do
estimation for the whole population we
can do the estimation of the population
mean
we can do the estimation of other
population parameters with the help of a
sample analysis
okay
so for estimation we use
special statistic like
Z statistic T statistic
okay
after estimation uh if I look at the
application of international statistics
we come across hypothesis testing
so we'll talk about hypothesis testing
as well with the help of some examples
but any questions so far with whatever
we have discussed
anybody feel free please
awesome
I know and you also know that we are not
delving deeper into any concept because
we have time limitation here
but I'm trying to give you an idea about
uh statistics influential and
descriptive statistics
can there be a point where you drop
assumption
yeah
uh
we need to sometimes use assumptions
to come up with a good results
okay
but we should know what we are doing
that is important
so that we can make the decision
correctly so yes we need to make
assumptions and assumptions are made in
all the types of Sciences
to get to the possible to get to the
best possible results
right and then we take care of
the reality as well later on
okay
let me take up a couple of more
questions
uh which were the two descriptive
statistical applications you mentioned
uh when collecting a sample
so when you collect the sample you don't
use descriptive statistics I only talked
about
the importance of collecting sample
okay once you have your sample once you
have your population then you perform
descriptive or infinitial statistics
okay what I may
I matter I told you that
you have to be careful when you collect
your data
because
you need to make your sample as
representative as possible of the
population because ultimately you make
your decision for the population you
don't make your decision decision for
the sample so you just don't go and
select anything you need to be careful
you need to take care of the fact that
the sample should be a good
representative
absolutely
there are a set of questions we which
we need to answer which which we need to
address before we collect the data
and that's why we have different types
of sampling techniques as well we have
probabilistic sampling techniques
non-probialistic sampling techniques
we have simple random sampling
systematic sampling
stratified sampling
cluster sampling and so on and so forth
so different types of sampling
techniques we have and we choose the
technique according to the constraint we
walk under according to a business
requirement according to different other
aspects
okay because ultimately everything
depends on the sample that is the basic
premise your whole analysis is based on
that only I hope I addressed your
question right
uh great uh one uh important term very
interesting term here we have predictive
statistics
uh which uh helps us to do Predictive
Analytics
so what we do in predictive statistics
foreign
what do we do in predictive statistics
how how does that help
nice thanks for your responses
absolutely
absolutely I agree with you
but let's not limit it to forecasting so
when you come up with futures
numbers
you call it forecast
if I talk about predictive statistics
it's more about
uh if I summarize it if I make it very
simple for you it's about
estimating the unknown
it's more about estimating the unknown
if that unknown
is in the future
we call it forecasting
right
so it's all about estimation
and we spend a lot of time in our course
to learn Predictive Analytics
absolutely
thanks folks for making this session so
interest interesting
to estimate what could come next
absolutely
I I agree with you
uh
but this estimation is not random it is
not a random guess
it is calculated based on statistical
significance
so statistics helps you
to do the estimation
it helps you to calculate the risk
nobody has seen the future any
statistics does not let you see the
future
but it definitely helps you to measure
the uncertainties to some extent
so that you can take
better decisions that is the whole idea
right
great I appreciate your questions here
okay
uh we learn here data categorization
types of data
so these details I'm not getting into
that they may not interest you at this
point of your learning uh too much of
mathematics too much of theory you may
find it as
uh so I'm kind of skipping this all
let me open
Advanced statistics and talk a little
about hypothesis testing
hypothesis
you understand this term hypothesis so
these terms if you remember I mentioned
t-test
hypothesis this term hypothesis you
understand
let me uh get you into my one note
what is hypothesis
do you see my one note where I am
scribbling
great
so let's set some background here for
hypothesis
yeah nice
so let me tell you uh
in our world
any statement which is not
uh Ruben
by statistics
which is not backed by facts
that remains hypothesis that remains an
assumption until proven
statistically That Remains
an assumption
okay
so nowadays
all the businesses
are driven by I would use a term driven
they are driven by analytics they are
driven by data science
okay so uh you just can't do anything
based on your gut feeling
if you're feeling you have some feel I
mean some intuition you are getting or
uh you have some other calculations and
you think this calculation may be
correct
in this
uh business scenario
you need to check that you need to test
that
so hypothesis testing becomes a very
important technique
so hypothesis testing helps you
to test your hypotheses
hypothesis testing helps you to perform
some Advanced analysis as well
okay
in fact
if you start with any new problem if you
start with any new data
it is very difficult to take the very
first step very difficult it is how to
start from it is always a big question
okay so how you start
you start by
testing your hypotheses
suppose
you come across the sales of different
products
and you find that sales for a particular
product
has come down
in the quarter as compared to previous
quarters significant
reduction
in the growth in the sales figures
if you find that
now
you would always like to delve deeper
you always want to understand the
reasons why
such a drop in sales
okay
so say so sales might have declined
because of several reasons
there may be economic reasons political
reasons
sales might have come down because of
incompetent product
because of product Packaging
because of incompetent sales
organization
because of ineffective marketing
because of bad after sales services
there's so many reasons
we always get kind of plummoxed as to
where to start from
right
so you create all your hypotheses
what may be the reason so you just write
down all your hypotheses
and then you brainstorm amongst your
team members what they think about it
sometimes you may have to talk to your
client and understand what they think
about the problem
you may also have to go for a focused
group discussions
and try to understand what others think
bringing in external perspective is also
very important
for any problem solving for that matter
Okay so all in all what you do you first
of all first of all collect all the
hypotheses all the Alternatives which
you think may help you solve any problem
at hand and then you start testing
while testing those hypotheses
you come across amazing results
and sometimes that lead to while doing
hypothesis testing you get led to some
amazing further analysis further
deep down analysis and you uh come up
with a great relationships great
patterns
okay
so I think now you understand the
importance of hypothesis testing and if
you don't know hypothesis testing it
becomes challenging for you
to learn Advanced Techniques like
regression logistic regression time
series analysis everywhere you'll use
this so hypothesis testing
in itself is a very important technique
and then it is used in other techniques
as well
okay
we will get an idea about hypothesis
testing with the help of one example
okay
let's start with
a case related to
a credit card company
let me ask you a question
what do you think is the main source of
income for a credit card company
what is the male source of income for a
for a credit card company tell me
thanks for your responses a lot many
responses this time that's good I always
knew that case study is interested
and that's why in the classes I make
sure I discuss every concept with the
help of cases with the help of case
studies because ultimately you learn all
these things so that you can do the
application
effectively
so a very interesting answers coming up
isn't it fun great
so
late fees interest fees
they make money from sales
a broke people
very interesting
let me tell you uh
majority of the revenue a credit card
company gets from
interchange fees you understand
interchange fees
interchange yeah great
so when you make any transaction
at a merchant location
some part of that transaction goes in
the pocket of the credit card company
it's a complex
a phenomena it is not that
straightforward there are multiple
entities involved but I'm making it
simple for you
there are requires Channel partners
and then ensure bank is there so
multiple entities are involved but I'm
making it very simple for you
if you go to any Merchant
say you go to Walmart and
swipe your card for a hundred dollars
uh say around two dollars will go to the
credit card company
so that is a very
uh significant uh proportion of their
revenue
all in all what I want to convey to you
here that Merchants are very important
for a credit card company so a credit
card company
runs its business in two directions
B2B as well as B to C
B to b means when they
do their business
with
Merchants directly and
b2c means when they
do their business with
End customer and card holders
and card member
absolutely
so both the parts of both the types of
businesses both the sites of the
businesses are very important for any
credit card company so Merchants are
also very important
foreign
company
to ensure that their Merchants are
satisfied the merchants are
kind of delighted
Merchants right delighted customers
every company aspires
uh to have their customers delighted
right
and it is important
that
they measure their satisfaction
they measure
how their customers how their Merchants
are feeling about the company what are
their sentiments and for that purpose
periodic surveys are conducted
the different types of surveys
and in those surveys sometimes a very
important question is asked
How likely you are to recommend
my product my services
to your friends to your colleagues have
you ever come across such question in
any survey I'm sure you must have
yeah I knew
so with the help of this question
actually a very important metric is
calculated
across industry this metric is very
important the name of this metric is is
NPS what is NPS guys
so there are ways to make people answer
the service
right
so you have a point
there are methods to make people
fill the survey
you can go for Google or chat GPT is
also there to help because right
in the morning uh one of my students
shared with shared with me one poem on
machine learning
at first instance I thought like it is
something actually written by that
student then I realized oh
it is chat GPT
okay so coming back here
NPS yes absolutely I got to many
responses net promoter score
so when
that question is asked
as to how
likely you are to recommend the product
or service
to your colleagues to your friends to
your family members Etc you're asked to
rate on the scale of
one to ten
one two three four five six seven eight
nine and ten
if somebody is giving 9 or 10 that
person is considered to be
promoters
and if
somebody's giving anything between one
to six that person is considered to be
detractor
and for seven and eight
passive
percentage promoter minus percentage
detracted this gives you NPS
so basically NPS
is used to understand customer
sentiments it is considered to be a very
important Matrix
and rightly so don't you think so
if somebody is ready to
recommend your product
if somebody is willing to recommend your
services your product to other people it
means they are actually happy am I right
Common Sense should Prevail right
so NPS is very helpful
so I just kind of set up the background
here now let's come to the
real point of concern the problem
so suppose after the survey you got
data
respond to data
in this data you have name of the
merchant name of merchant
name of the merchant
uh you've got
marketing channel
or Communication channel whatever you
want to name it
and then we have
the score let's go to that question
you're absolutely correct Deborah I
agree with you
Okay so we've got name of the merchants
marketing channel and score
I'll make it simple for you uh suppose
we've got two channels here
face to face
and the second channel is
telecommunication telecommunication
now tell me
prima facie what do you think which
channel is more effective
is it face to face or telecommunication
so I can see here most of you are
responding with face to face
and let me tell you management
also
things in the same way suppose
I'm sharing one case with you a business
case management always
had this opinion that face-to-face
communication
is very effective
when you are sending your representative
to meet the customer in person
the level of communication is much
better
Merchant is able to share
the give answers the issues
easily
and also
the representative of the credit card
company
that person that employee of the company
is also able to communicate effectively
different offers
different promotional offers different
schemes different
ways of working new products
okay etc etc so the communication
becomes much easier much smooth
when it comes to face-to-face
communication
at
we discussed at the beginning
it is only assumption
until proven by numbers
until proven by empirically driven
methodologies
it remains hypothesis only
so it is a hypothesis
okay and that hypothesis has to be
tested
okay
here something very important is
the first step which is to State your
hypothesis statement we can't write our
hypothesis in English because here we
are going to follow a procedure
here we are going to follow
a well-established methodology and for
that we need to write our hypothesis in
a very specific way
we write our hypothesis in two lines
first line is called as null hypothesis
and second line is called as
alternate
hypothesis
null hypothesis is represented by S
naught an alternate is represented by h
a
I'm gonna tell you something here
one concept how to write null and
Alternate and then I'll ask you a
question okay so be ready
everybody please listen to me carefully
here because right after this I'll be
asking you a question I'll be asking you
how to set up
this hypothesis statement for this
situation okay so be very carefully
listening to me
in null hypothesis what we write
we write
condition
which leads to
status quo
and in hav write
that condition
which leads to
change
okay
by the way what is the status quo
what is the status quo
so if I search for this word on Google
if you look for the meaning of this
world
uh the meaning is
existing state of affairs
right
the meaning is existing a state of
affairs
so a status quo is about what is
prevalent what people think
right
what has been the situation
okay that that is your status quo
okay
so in another hypothesis what you do you
write
that condition
which you will get after the analysis
which least leads to status quo so you
write here that condition
which you may get after the analysis
which may lead to the status quo that
you write in null hypothesis
okay so what should be the null
hypothesis here
or let me ask you another wave what is
the status quo here in this situation
in this situation the status quo is
people believe
that face to face is the best way to
interact absolutely
that face to face is better that people
believe
now after this whole analysis
which condition if you come up with will
need to status quo tell me
which condition if comes up with will
lead to stethoscope
after doing this whole analysis
which condition if you come up with
will lead to status quo
very good
very good answer
really appreciate
and I'm very happy to see your responses
it seems like
uh
you are actually listening to the whole
discussion so a couple of you answered
here very well
really happy to see your responses
so my time time investment uh is
worthwhile here I'm happy very good
so if we write here
NPS
from face to face
is more than NPS from
telecommunication
in this scenario let me write it a
little more clearly
so in s naught
you write here NPS from face to face is
more than NPS from telecommunication
and in ha you write NPS from face to
face is less than NPS from Theory
communication
okay
so uh
if after the analysis you come up with
this condition if you are able to deduce
that NPS from face to face is more than
LPS from telecommunication what will
happen
I'll tell you what
it is interesting
your management believes that face to
face is a better way of communication
and after doing this analysis after
spending like
uh
two three days you collect your data you
clean your data and then you do the
analysis after three days suppose you
go to your management and you tell your
management that you have done this
analysis and this analysis shows that
face to face is a better way of
communication
you know what will be the response of
those people
come on why you wasted your three days I
was already telling you
so uh these type of responses you should
be ready to hear right
it was only for fun but you understand
what it means so people will keep doing
what they have been doing they were
investing a lot of money into
face-to-face communication face-to-face
communication requires investment a lot
of investment
while Kelly communication is not that
costly it is cheaper
right
uh I'm happy that you are enjoying the
session great
[Music]
but in case
you come up with
the second one which you have written in
alternate
that NPS from face to face is less than
NPS from telecommunication
that will lead to
changes
and it will be something big why it will
be big
because
it will impact
the dollars directly
is it it
because face to face is a very costly
medium
you are sending your representative
to meet the customers it is costly
and if
uh despite interesting uh such a huge
amount of money if Merchants are not
happy if the customers are not happy why
would you at all
go for face to face
you were to stick to telecommunication
cheaper
and effective is it
now the next part is
after setting up the hypothesis
statement the next part is testing
testing requires
more in-depth discussion
for testing you need
evidences
and in terms of evidences
you derive
a statistical term called p-value
and you compare it with something called
significance level
and then you finally conclude
statement is correct
okay
so
this is hypothesis any question I'm
pretty much done with the hypothesis
testing uh whatever I have to discuss uh
I'm kind of short of time here uh
otherwise it is really fun uh discussing
all these concepts with you and
especially with people like you who are
interacting and I like interaction
uh great any question if you have I'm
happy to address
p-value requires normal distribution how
you assure a normal distribution
let me tell you it is not that uh
straightforward it's not one line answer
to your question
and
here we require
the application of central limit theorem
so with the help of central limit
theorem
we try to calculate p-value
okay
any other question
so significance level uh depends from
one situation to another
it's a kind of risk appetite
different people have different risk
appetite
different companies have different risk
appetite you have differences appetite
for different projects
right
generally five percent
is used across industry
but nothing casted over a stone
Central emitter illustrates that many
number of experiments lead to okay
uh
you are very close to what central limit
theorem tells you
and uh
if you know Central limit theorem you
know that if the sample size is adequate
if you have large enough sample size
then the distribution of sample means
will be normal and that
information you can use to calculate
p-value okay I'm I'm uh so happy to see
your curious curiosity your
inquisitiveness that is uh the first
step to learn anything
so this is the very first step to learn
anything and that you have so that's
great
yes absolutely it also depends on which
test it is whether it is one sample test
it is two sample test it is three or
more sample test and then uh whether it
is two-sided or one-sided one tail two
tail a lot many aspects here hypothesis
testing takes time to understand
any other question
I told you
uh nothing casted over a stone
but generally it is five percent
sure so it's what I'm pretty much done
with the agenda
and you can very well take over and if
anybody has any question I'm happy to
answer
okay
um
I'm only jumping in because we are about
the end of the hour we had scheduled for
the webinar
so I wanted to cover a couple of things
before we leave but first I want to
remind everybody that this is the type
of class that you would take within the
data science boot camp so that's the
kind of interaction you have during the
live instruction and there's also a lot
of other
aspects to the boot camp including
preparation through pre-recorded videos
being able to review your classes
through class recordings being able to
do the exercises on the Live Lab
environment is
uh each of them demonstrated so
I hope this gave you a flavor of what
the the course is like I'm going to just
before we uh
finish the webinar I just want to cover
a couple of quick points about the
program and ask you a couple of
questions in the audience
the data science boot camp is a six
month program
it's fully on through the learning
management system as you just saw oops
my
will quit for a second but I'll be right
back so bear with me
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
something that happens when uh
when I switched to screen sharing
apologize for that so again it's six
months we'd say you should devote about
10 hours a week because there's uh most
weeks there's live classes with
instructors like show them um
on the weekends four hour Saturday for
our Sunday
um plus the integrated labs in between
which you can do anytime 24 7. so you
can fit the class work homework outside
of the class time anytime
you have time for it pretty much
covers everything
in any schedule that a working person
has the good thing also about this boot
camp is it's open practically everyone
you only need to be 18 years of age or
older with a high school diploma for the
educational requirement we prefer that
you have a couple of years of work
experience
so that you understand the applications
of data in the work environment this
doesn't have to be work experience in
data processing data science or data
analytics can be any work experience but
this gives you a
idea for the context in which
data science is used and you do have to
have some prior knowledge
or experience with programming Concepts
and
as part of the service also as part of
the boot camp after you complete it we
do provide assistance with your job
search so if you're taking the boot camp
to find a new position you'll have six
months after the end of the program to
access these Services if you're a
student in the USA
fortunately we don't have these outside
of the U.S or Canada but we do
provide other services to help you with
your job search so
I want to ask a question of our audience
how much experience
do you have and I'll just
quick question
I'll just leave this open for another 10
seconds because it's pretty
straightforward
I'll close this in five or three two one
so we have a fairly seasoned audience 75
of your out of uh out of school and
I assume that most of you who are
currently studying are in college or
university so
presuming that practically everyone here
will be qualified from the education and
experience standpoint
share that with you
and then
let's move on
just so you know the program is eight
thousand dollars but you have a bonus
for attending this sample class because
you're here today we will give you a 500
discount off of the program fees
um and you can also ask your employer if
you have a tuition reimbursement
um benefit at your work
so all of that can help you with this
program
cohort starting May 15th has an
induction session tomorrow
but there will be other induction
sessions if you can't quite make
tomorrows
and classes start May 15th and there are
also of course cohorts starting
pretty much monthly after that so reach
out to us at ask us simplylearn.net and
I'm going to put that information into
chat for everyone
that includes the URL for the program
home page on our website
and last a couple questions here quickly
so I
just a gauge
get a general idea this is not a promise
this you don't have to commit but
curious to know who's interested
and how soon you'd like to start
I'll leave this open just for another
five seconds
or three
two
one
hey
nearly 80 percent of you more than three
quarters
um are interested and
about 30 percent want to get started
either uh in the May classes or maybe
June July so again contact us and ask us
at simplylearn.net
and last question for you is do you want
us to reach out to you uh to help you
with enrollment ask answer any questions
or do you want to get a proof of
attendance for this class
and if you answer yes to the question we
will be sending
that to you
close in five four three
two one
so for those of you who answered yes we
will
send out
um
a proof of attendance and we'll also
reach out to you to see if you have any
questions that we can help you with
and with that
we've reached the end of our webinar
our sample class from the Caltech data
science boot camp
again you have the URL and the email
address you can contact us I want to
thank shubham very much for sharing his
expertise and his time today
taking us through the learning
experience
teaching us about the fundamentals of
statistics for data science
well thank you
thank you so much for having me here it
was fun thank you
okay and I want to thank everybody in
our audience today for being here taking
the time to sample the program and we
want to
invite you to join our Learning
Community with simply learning Caltech
we hope to see you in the future that
completes our webinar